♪ ♪
>> Greg: WELCOME BACK.
A LIVE LOOK AT THE WHITE HOUSE
WHERE THE CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE
IS SET TO HOLD A BRIEFING
MOMENTS FROM NOW AND WE WILL
TAKE YOU THERE ONCE IT STARTS.
IN THE MEANTIME LAWMAKERS SAY
THERE ARE A LOT CLOSER TO THE
DEAL IN A $2 TRILLION AID
PACKAGE AFTER DEMOCRATS BLOCKED
OF BILL TWO DAYS IN A ROW.
CHUCK SCHUMER AND NANCY PELOSI
ARE NOW OPTIMISTIC ABOUT WORKING
WITH REPUBLICANS BUT ONLY AFTER
BEING EXPOSED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLING OUT THE
DEMOCRATS WERE PUSHING ELEMENTS
OF THE GREEN NEW DEAL THE
NEGOTIATIONS.
>> President Trump: WE ALMOST
HAD A DEAL THE DAY BEFORE AND IT
WAS BETWEEN SCHUMER AND MITCH
AND IT WAS A GOOD SOLID DEAL.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY START
THROWING ALL OF THE LITTLE GREEN
NEW DEAL STUFF IN THEM.
IN THE BOARDROOMS AND WHAT THEY
LOOK LIKE.
WE WANT TO GREEN ENERGY, WE WANT
ALL THE STUFF.
LET’S STOP DRILLING OIL.
THEY HAVE THINGS IN THERE THAT
WERE TERRIBLE.
WINDOWS ALL OVER THE PLACE AND
ALL SORTS OF CREDITS FOR
WINDMILLS.
THEY KILLED THE BIRDS AND RUIN
THE REAL ESTATE.
LOTS OF PROBLEMS, I MEAN A LOT
OF PROBLEMS.
>> Greg: AND EVEN THOUGH
NANCY PELOSI’S OWN BILL WAS
FILLED WITH WIND AND TAX
CREDITS, $35 MILLION FOR THE
KENNEDY CENTER AND CORPORATE
BOARD DIVERSITY STANDARDS, THE
SPEAKER CLAIMS THAT’S NOT THE
CASE.
>> THAT’S NOT A BILL I WOULD
HAVE WRITTEN IN TERMS OF FAMILY
MEDICAL LEAVE OR WORKER
PROTECTIONS, RULING ON WORKER
PROTECTIONS BUT THAT CAN BE DONE
NEXT ADMINISTRATIVELY, WE CAN
FIND OTHER WAYS.
NOT ENOUGH MONEY FOR ELECTIONS
ET CETERA AT THIS TIME.
EVERYTHING WE ARE SUGGESTING
RELATES TO COVID-19, NOT ABOUT
MAKING LAW FOR THE FUTURE.
>> Greg: KATIE, TAKES A LOT OF
YOU KNOW WHAT TO SHOEHORN SOME
OF THE STUFF IN THERE.
DID THEY THINK NO ONE WAS GOING
TO FIND OUT WHAT THE STRATEGY
WAS?
KATIE?
>> Katie: OH, SORRY JESSE,
THERE WAS A BREAK IN YOUR
MICROPHONE.
I THINK THE STRATEGY WAS THAT
NANCY PELOSI SAW AN OPPORTUNITY
TO WALK ALL OVER CHUCK SCHUMER
IN THE SENATE AND SAY WE ARE
GOING TO PUSH A LOT OF THESE
UNRELATED PORK PROJECTS INTO THE
BILL BECAUSE NO ONE IS GOING TO
QUESTION US ON IT BECAUSE IT’S
AN EMERGENCY.
IT’S A GOOD THING REPUBLICANS
WERE PAYING ATTENTION BECAUSE
$35 MILLION TO THE KENNEDY
CENTER IS AN AFFRONT TO
TAXPAYERS EVERYWHERE.
AMERICANS ARE LOSING THEIR JOBS
AND THEY WANT TO TAKE
HARD-EARNED MONEY FROM THEM AND
GIVE IT TO THE KENNEDY CENTER
WHEN THEY COULD BE DOING PRIVATE
FUND-RAISERS.
THE OTHER ISSUE THAT IS ALARMING
IS THE PUSHING THROUGHOUT THE
FEDERAL LYSING OF OUR ELECTIONS
WITH THE BALLOT HARVESTING AND
THE LONG-TERM EFFECTS OF THE
EARLY VOTING THEY WANTED TO PUSH
THROUGH ON THIS.
I MEAN NANCY PELOSI HAS SEEN AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE AND
CHUCK SCHUMER WHO SAID SUNDAY
THAT EVERYTHING WAS GOING ALONG
JUST FINE LET HER WALK IN AND
WALK ALL OVER HIM AND BLEW UP
THE WHOLE SYSTEM ON BEHALF OF
DEMOCRATS SEEKING POWER RATHER
THAN WORKING ON SOMETHING THAT
WILL HELP EVERYBODY REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THEY ARE REPUBLICAN
OR DEMOCRAT.
>> Greg: JUAN, DANA MADE THAT
POINT THE OTHER DAY, EVERYTHING
WAS GOING SWIMMINGLY UNTIL NANCY
SHOWED UP AND MADE CHECK KIND OF
CATER TO HER EVERY WHIM AT THE
LAST SECOND AND ROCKED THE
MARKETS.
DO YOU THINK CHUCK SCHUMER SAW
THAT COMING OR WAS HE TAKEN BY
SURPRISE?
>> Juan: I THINK THIS WHOLE
DESCRIPTION THAT WE ARE GOING
THROUGH RIGHT NOW IS A
CARICATURE.
I THINK WHAT’S GOING ON IS
DEMOCRATS ARE OUT ABOUT
PROTECTING AMERICA’S WORKERS.
AND I THINK THE STICKING POINT
HAS BEEN THAT THERE WAS MONEY
BEING SET ASIDE FOR CORPORATIONS
CORPORATIONS, THE BIG
CORPORATIONS, TO MAKE SURE THEY
DIDN’T GO UNDER, BUT THAT THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THAT
MONEY.
THEY DIDN’T WANT THOSE BIG
CORPORATIONS TO SIMPLY GET
LOCKED INTO BUYBACKS AND
EXECUTIVE PAY RAISES, THEY WANT
TO MAKE SURE THOSE COMPANIES ARE
PROTECTING AND KEEPING WORKERS
DURING THIS TIME.
AND I THINK THAT IS WHAT WE SAW
NOW FROM THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Greg: WHAT DOES THAT HAVE
TO DO WITH THE GREEN NEW DEAL
THOUGH?
>> Juan: IT DOES, THE WAY WE
PRESENTED IT THIS EVENING AS A
CARICATURE OF WHAT’S REALLY
GOING ON.
>> Greg: OH, I DIDN’T NOTICE
THAT.
>> Juan: I THINK THE PRESIDENT
IS QUICK TO SAY HE CAN PUT
DEMOCRATS AT A DISADVANTAGE BY
MAKING IT SEEM AS THOUGH THEY
ARE INVOLVED IN SOME KIND OF
POWER GRAB OR SELF-PROMOTION OF
SOME WILD AGENDA, BUT YOU GO
BACK AND YOU LOOK AT TARP, YOU
KNOW THE TROUBLED ASSET RELIEF
PROGRAM FROM 2008 AND YOU WILL
SEE SIMILAR PROTECTIONS ARE IN
THERE AND AGAIN, SO MANY
AMERICANS FELT THE BIG BUSINESS
IS TOO BIG TO FAIL.
THEY’VE GOT MONEY.
BUT THE AVERAGE PERSON, AND
JESSE, YOU AND I AGREED ON THIS
YESTERDAY.
YOU HAVE TO PUT MORE MONEY IN
THE AVERAGE PERSON’S POCKET TO
SPEND.
>> Greg: I DIDN’T KNOW THAT’S
WHAT THEY WERE TRYING TO DO.
IT’S BEEN ONE OF THE REALITY IS
THEY NEED MORE FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
RELIEF.
>> Jesse: I GOT YOU.
GREG, WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS RELIEF PACKAGE?
>> Greg: THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN
FIND A VIRUS IS THROUGH
DIVERSITY.
SO I’M HAPPY THAT’S A PRIORITY.
LOOK, WE ARE ALL MAKING
SACRIFICES, I’VE SAID THAT
BEFORE.
BUT WHAT’S DEPRESSING IS THE
VERY SAME PEOPLE ARE UP TO THE
VERY SAME TRICKS EVEN WHEN TIMES
ARE URGENT AND UGLY.
LIKE I GET IT WITH THE NORMAL
STUFF.
WHEN YOU DO THE NORMAL BUDGET
SNEAK ALL THE STUFF IN THAT YOU
CAN TO GET REELECTED BUT THAT’S
NOT THIS TIME.
WHAT’S DOUBLY DEPRESSING AS WE
HONESTLY DON’T KNOW WHO’S DOING
IT.
WE COULD SAY NANCY FLEW IN AND
SAID, STOP IT!
BUT SHE PROBABLY DIDN’T WRITE
THIS STUFF.
SHE DIDN’T DO IT, CHUCK DIDN’T
DO IT, THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
HAPPY TO SIGN IT AND GO BACK AND
HAVE A GLASS OF WINE.
SO NO ONE EVER KNOWS WHO IS
SCREWING THIS UP.
IT’S NOT DEMOCRATS AND IT’S NOT
ALL REPUBLICANS, WHO ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE MAKING THIS SO
COMPLICATED AND WHERE IS THE
MEDIA?
THAT’S A GREAT STORY.
RATHER THAN SCREWING UP EVERY
STORY ABOUT THE VIRUS, TRY TO
FIND OUT WHO THE PEOPLE ARE WHO
ARE MOCKING THIS UP.
THEN, WE CAN FIRE THOSE CREEPS.
>> Jesse: IS PROBABLY THE
LOBBYISTS BUT WHAT DO I KNOW.
DANA, IT WOULD BE LIKE IF
REPUBLICANS TRY TO JIMMY IN
DEFUNDING PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
IF THAT HAPPENS, THE MEDIA WOULD
GO WILD.
>> Dana: THE MEDIA WOULD FIND
THAT ONE.
THAT WOULD NOT BE HARD FOR THEM
TO FIND.
THE $35 MILLION FOR THE KENNEDY
CENTER IS THE NEW BRIDGE TO
NOWHERE, REMEMBER THAT?
LIKE WHY ARE WE DOING THIS?
I’M ALL FOR THE ARTS BUT THIS IS
NOT THE TIME OR THE PLACE.
IF NANCY PELOSI THINKS THAT THIS
WASN’T SOMETHING SHE WANTED IN
THERE, THEN SHE HAS TO POLICE
HER TROOPS A LITTLE BIT BETTER
BECAUSE THEY LOOK REALLY BAD.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS CAME -- IF
YOU THINK ABOUT THE SCHUMER SHUT
DOWN, EVERY TIME THEY WANT TO
FIGHT AGAINST THE PRESIDENT THEY
END UP WITH EGG ON THEIR FACE.
>> Jesse: SHE IS FIGHTING FOR
THE WORKERS, THE WORKERS AT THE
KERRY CENTER.